ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANT
AT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO
THE FLOOR.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
I AGREE ARE CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
JUNE.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LEóN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS.
REYES THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS IN THE GALLERY.
IN OUR VISITORS IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THIS AFTERNOON'S PRAYER.
MEMBERS THIS AFTERNOON'S FEREBEE
OFFERED BY THEIR MOTHERS TO
MINISTER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I FIND IT REFRESHING TO REMEMBER
THAT OUR NATION IS A COUNTRY
FOUNDED BY RELUCTANT REBELS.
RELUCTANT BECAUSE BEFORE
DECLARING INDEPENDENCE THE TRIED
REASON AND DIPLOMACY.
THE CLEARLY BOARDED THEIR
INTENTION TO REBEL EXPLAINING
THAT.
WHEN IN THE COURSE OF HUMAN
EVENTS CIRCUMSTANCES CAN ARISE
THAT LEAVE US WITH NO REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE?
IN OTHER WORDS KING GEORGE TIMES
UP.
OUR FOUNDERS WERE REBELLING
AGAINST OPPRESSION DECLARING
THAT TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION IS TYRANNY.
THEY WERE PEOPLE WHO FELT
EXCLUDED AND INVISIBLE.
THE FELT USED AND ABUSED WITHOUT
A VOICE OR A CHOICE.
IT IS INTRIGUING TO CONSIDER
THAT OUR NATION WAS FOUNDED BY
PEOPLE WHO FELT DISENFRANCHISED.
DISRESPECTED IN MARGINALIZED.
THE AMERICAN REVOLUTION GAVE
BIRTH TO NOT ONLY A NATION BUT
TO THE WHOLE THAT FREEDOM ANY
QUALITY WERE INDEED POSSIBLE.
FOR TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
YEARS WE HAVE BEEN A DREAM IN
PROGRESS.
IN IDEA THAT CONTINUES TO TRY TO
FIND ITS WAY.
THE DREAM OF INCLUSION AND
EQUALITY IS A GREAT DREAM.
IT IS A DREAM WORTHY OF PURSUING
PROUDLY WITH UNENDING COMMITMENT
AND DEVOTION.
NOW MORE ME THEM WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU EVER NOTICED.
MR LACKEY AS A MEMBER LACKEY IS
RECOGNIZED FOR BUT AS HE LEADS
US OUR PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
[inaudible]
READY AGAIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND IT IS A LITTLE [inaudible]
THE SONG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED
--
READ OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JUNE TWENTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE SOME ABOUT
AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE CECILIA
I AM AT WORK.
THE CHOIR CURRY SWIMMER POINT IS
A PRESIDING BISHOP BONTA MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL SHALL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE -- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
IN ALL ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN OUR DAILY
JOURNAL.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE. ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AROUND THE
LAUGH FRIEDMAN COME LONGER DOVE
MATHIS GABRIEL SANTIAGO AND
RUBIO. TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR THEIR
GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT THEIR
DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW US IN THE
MEMBERS BLOOM.
AND FRAZIER TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PLEASE RETURN AB SIX OH FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN TO THE SENATE FOR
FURTHER ACTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE OFFICE
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER NINETY EIGHT SB.
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE AND ITEM NUMBER ONE OH
FOUR SB THREE NINETY EIGHT THAT
ALSO.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
AND WITHDRAW A. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE DOLLY FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE
BILL TO THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE SB SIX TWENTY ONE
GLAZER. FOR THEIR HEARING ON
TUESDAY JULY NINTH PENDING RE
REFER ALL FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
SO TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RE REFER ITEM NUMBER ONE OH TWO
SB TWO THIRTY NINE CHIANG. TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE.
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOU GARCIA TO
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SB TWO HUNDRED MINING
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
MISS WALDRON WE WOULD HOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT ON US FOR ROLL
CALL [inaudible]
GOOD.
MEMBERS THIS MOTION REQUIRES A
SECOND.
MR GIPSON SECONDS OF MEMBERS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MS.
I'M SORRY MR MATHIS.
AND SO I MISSED [inaudible]
THIS.
MEMBERS MISTER MATHIS HAS SECOND
IT.
I MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISS WALDRON THAT'S BEEN
SECONDED BY MISTER MATHIS.
THIS MEANT THIS MOTION IS NOT
DEBATABLE.
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES FORTY
BUCKS.
CLICK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS MISS WALDRON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER BONTA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
CLICKING CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE.
EITHER TO KNOW THE FORTY FOURTH
THAT MOTION FAILS
-- MEMBERS FOR
CLARIFICATION.
PREVIOUS MOTION WAS BY MISTER
BONTA WAS SECONDED BY MISTER
GIPSON.
THERE WAS THIS WILL TAKE FORTY
VOTES.
ACTION.
YOU HAVE PROBLEMS.
MEMBERS THE PREVIOUS ACTION IS
RESENTED WE WILL BE VOTING THIS
MATTER TO TAKE PROPER ACTION IS
A MOTION BY MISTER BONTA SECOND
BY MISTER GIPSON CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS MISTER BONTA IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MISS WALDRON IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE OF ALL IN TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY FIVE
KNOWS.
SIX THAT MOTION CARRIES.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO GAS
INTRODUCTIONS.
WITH A NUMBER OF MEMBERS HERE
WISHING TO MAKE AN INDUCTION SO
THEY MEMBERS SO WE WILL GO. TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR INDULGING ME
I WANTED TO PRODUCE MY SON ETHAN
WHO JOIN ME TODAY HE IS THREE
YEARS OLD.
HE LOVES SHARKS IN WALES AND ALL
KINDS OF SEA CREATURES AND I
BROUGHT HIM UP TO HER TODAY TO
TEACH HIM THAT.
DEMOCRACY IS NOT A SPECTATOR
SPORT SO PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME
MY SON ETHAN TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL WELCOME
EVEN.
MEMBERS -- GOT OUT A SEMI MEMBER
COM LONGER DOES YOUR RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR IN YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO INTRODUCE
MY STEP SON AUSTIN DAB JUNIOR
WHO WILL BE.
ENTERING INTO SEVENTH GRADE --
COME THIS FALL HE'S VERY CURIOUS
TO SEE WHAT HIS STEP MOTHER DOES
FOUR DAYS OUT OF THE WEEK WHEN
SHE IS NOT HOME.
SO I WANTED HIM TO COME UP HERE
AND SEE MY NEW COLLEAGUES.
I GUESS THIS IS ALSO A SHOUT OUT
TO ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO GET
MARRIED TO FOLKS WHO ALSO HAVE
CHILDREN STEP MOTHER.
AND STEPFATHER'S BRING IT HOME
EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER.
WELCOME AUSTIN.
THE THREAT IS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTERACTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
WITH ME TODAY IS -- ONE OF MY
MANY ME -- LUKE SAMUEL MATHIS
ACHEI THE MOOSE -- IS REALLY
EXCITED TO BE A FAIR ANY KEEPS
SAYING THAT AS SOON AS I'M DONE
TALKING IS TAKING OVER MY JOB SO.
WISH HIM LUCK.
WELCOME JACKSON GLAD TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
WITH MY KID ALSO IN EVEN I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE CAME UP HERE
PARTICULARLY OUT THE FOURTH OF
JULY TO CELEBRATE WHAT WE DO IN
THE CAPITAL.
AND TO HELP US MOVE A GOOD
LEGISLATION TO THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SAID IAGO
WELCOME EATEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS AND
ADOPTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE DAYS OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE THIS IS THE DAY WHEN SO
MANY OF US BRING OUR CHILDREN UP.
AND TODAY I HAVE MY DAUGHTER
REACH WITH ME AND I AM SO HAPPY
THAT SO MANY OF YOU HAVE BECOME
FRIENDS OF HERS A GREAT ROLE
MODEL ALSO.
THANKS EVERYBODY AND WELCOME
RACHEL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN WELL -- WELCOME RACHEL.
GLAD TO BE HERE THE UNOFFICIAL
BRING YOUR CHILD TO WORK DAY
EVERYBODY.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE -- FORGIVE ME.
I APOLOGIZE MS RUBIO YOU'RE NOT
ON MY LIST OF IT GOT SENATE
ACTIONS BUT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS ARE CONNECTION
THANK YOU MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THE THIRD
RUBIO SISTER AND SHE DOES NOT
LIKE SHARKS IN WALES AND NOT.
WATER ANIMALS BUT SHE'S HERE ARE.
CELEBRATING WITH BOTH HER%
SISTERS SHE WAS IN THE SENATE OR
YEAR AND SHE'S WITH US TODAY AND
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME.
THAT THIRD REPEAL SISTER SYLVA
RUBIO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
RUBIO WELCOME SO YET.
I'M IN MY PREVIOUS STATEMENT
BRING YOUR CHILD AND YOUR
SIBLINGS TO WORK DAY VERY GOOD.
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
INTRODUCTIONS WILL MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S IN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SIX
THREE SIXTEEN FOR TWENTY EIGHT
WITH A WOMEN'S ONE FIFTY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS ONE SIXTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS 629-924-05390. THREE
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT FIVE OH FIVE
FIVE OR 668-129-8680 THREE TO
NINETEEN WITH A MEMBERS FOR
NINETY WITH A MEMBERS FIVE TO
ALL THE MEMBERS FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN WITH A MINUTES TO FORTY
FIVE MINUTES. ONE SEVENTY ONE
WITH A MINUTE SIX NINETY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS ONE TWENTY ABLE TO
MANAGE TO NINE THREE WITHIN
MINUTES AND SENATE BILL.
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE ALL BILL AND
SENATE BILL.
TWO HUNDRED ALL HILLS DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
IT'S ABOUT THAT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE SB FIVE OH FIVE AMBURG
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS WILL START AT THE TOP OF
THE FILE
.
NUMBER STARTING AT THE TOP OF
THE FILE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE A ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HOUSING AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
ALL ONE IS OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL.
THIS BUILDS UPON THE SUCCESS OF
LAST YEAR'S HOMELESSNESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE THEY PREVENTION
PROGRAM.
PROVIDES JURISDICTION CITY
COUNTIES IN CONTINUES OF CARE
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE MEDIA
CHALLENGES AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTER DEVELOPMENTS.
IT CREATES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PLANNING SUPPORT GRANTS PROGRAM
TO ALLOCATE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION FOR REGIONS IN
JURISDICTIONS. TO CONDUCT PLAN
THE ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
SIX CYCLE OF THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
IT ALSO CREATES THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM OF
TWENTY NINETEEN TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS FOR
ELIGIBLE CITIES.
AND COUNTIES WITH A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS IT ALSO INCLUDES
FINES FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
NOT HOUSING.
ELEMENT COMPLIANCE IT ALSO
ALLOWS ALLOCATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THE NEW STATE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
ALSO PROPER IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THE CAL HFA IS MIXED
INCOME PROGRAM.
AND WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE OH ONE THANK YOU MISTER KING
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE OH ONE THE PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
INCREDIBLY SEVERE AND PERVASIVE.
DOWNED THE MEASURES OF THIS BILL
WILL HELP A LITTLE.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE TAKE A PAUSE HERE.
NOW TO HAVE A DISCUSSION AND DO
SOME INTROSPECTION ABOUT THE
PROBLEM OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE SOLUTIONS FOR
IT.
AND I THINK A HEALTHY PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION WOULD BE TO ASK
OURSELVES SOME QUESTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE.
IF WE CONTINUE TO SPEND
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE THAN OTHER
STATES ON THIS HOMELESS PROBLEM.
WHY DO WE CONTINUE O HAVE THE
HIGHEST HOMELESSNESS OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY?
IF WE CONTINUE TO FUND THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHY IS IT THAT WE CAN'T
BUILD.
A ONE UNIT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FOR LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
STATE AND WHY IS A COST US MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION DOLLARS TO
BUILD UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IN SOME PARTS OF OUR STATE
[inaudible]
AND FINALLY.
IF THIS S A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SOLVING FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS A CERTAINLY HAS
BEEN.
WHY DOES THIS PROBLEM CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE?
I'M SURE EVERYONE WAS PAYING
ATTENTION TO OUR POINT IN TIME
COUNTS IN THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS.
HOMELESSNESS IS INCREASED.
BY ALMOST 20% ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST YEAR.
SO I THINK IT'S KNOWS SECRET TO
THE PEOPLE THIS CHAMBER BUT THE
PROBLEM HOMELESS NEXT IS COMPLEX
AND MULTIFACETED IT'S FAR BEYOND
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
HOUSES.
IT HAS ITS ROOTS AND THINGS LIKE
MENTAL ILLNESS.
I IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
I HAD IN THE DECLINING FORTUNES
OF THE MIDDLE CLASS.
BUT TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IS
GOING TO REQUIRE HOLISTIC
APPROACHES TO SOLVING THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS OF WHY
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS AND UNTIL.
WE ARE WILLING TO TAKE THOSE
STEPS.
NEARLY THROWING MONEY AT THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE IT.
HOWEVER IF THIS IS THE BEST WE
CAN DO OF THIS YEAR MY ORIGINAL
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MEMBERS THAT ASK YOU TO GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
SPEAKERS.
AND ASK FOR CALM IN THE BACK OF
A CHAMBER PLEASE.
MR CHOOSE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK
OUR GOVERNOR AS WELL SO
LEADERSHIP OF OUR LEGISLATURE.
FOR COMING TOGETHER ON THIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL -- WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING THE MOST
INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY -- FROM THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT THAT WE HAVE
REPRESENTED IN THIS BILL TO THE
POLICIES TO ENSURE AN
APPROPRIATE.
SET OF CARROTS AND STICKS TO
MOVE JURISDICTIONS FOR THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY BUT I WANT
TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT AGREE --
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
AISLE WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU -- TO HOPEFULLY MOVING
MOVE US FORWARD SO THAT WE HAVE
A DAY WHERE THE NUMBERS THE
TRAGEDIES -- THE SUFFERING THAT
WERE SEEN NOW ON OUR STREETS ARE
DRESSED BUT WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ALL OF US -- TO REGISTER
TO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO SUPPORT AB.
ONE OH ONE THIS BILL PROMOTES
HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE
THROUGH INCENTIVES FIRST BEFORE
ALLOWING THE COURTS TO PURSUE
ESCALATING PENALTIES. TO FORCE
COMPLIANCE FOR ABOUT ACTORS.
I'M ESPECIALLY HAPPY THE SMALL
CITIES HAVE A SET ASIDE IN SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE RURAL AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES FACE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES IN ATTRACTING AND
DELIVERING HOUSING AND URBAN
AREAS.
THE BILL WILL GIVE LOCAL
AGENCIES A CHANCE TO USE THIS
FUNDING TO IMPROVE LOCAL
PLANNING STREAMLINED LOCAL
PROCESSES AND LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR ACTUALLY DELIVERING HOUSING.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
THAT ALLOWS THE COURT TO
CONSIDER MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHY A CITY OR
COUNTY MAY BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
OUR TENDENCY IS TO LUMP LOCALS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO ATTRACT
AND DELIVER HOUSING WITH THOSE
WHO INTENTIONALLY PUT BARRIERS
UP. TO DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
I WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SEEKING MY INPUT ON THIS
IMPORTANT HOUSING POLICY.
AND THANKS TO THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP THE BUDGET COMMITTEE --
IN BOTH HOUSES IN MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAFF FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL I ASK FOR
YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AS A MEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WANT
TO NOTE SOME OF THE PROVISIONS I
THINK ARE OF SPECIALLY IMPORTERS.
SIGNIFICAN HERE.
WE ESTABLISHED POLICY HERE SET
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT IS USED PROGRAMS GET
IMPLEMENTED.
FISH THERE SHALL BE CRITERIA
THAT CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF RURAL
SUBURBAN URBAN JURISDICTIONS.
AND THE FACT THAT THESE
JURISDICTIONS MAY DIFFER.
SO WE THE LEGISLATURE TELL THE
ADMINISTRATION THE HOUSING
AGENCY. TO DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY
TO A DOLLAR DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS THAT'S ACTUALLY
BASIC FAIRNESS.
WE DIDN'T GO ON AND GRANTS TO
THIS AGENCY.
THAT'S THE FRAMEWORK THE HONOR
DOLLARS HE'S DIFFERENCES BUT
THEN THEY CREATE THE LIST OF
WHICH ARE PRO HOUSING
JURISDICTIONS.
SO WE SAID NO ONE HAD
LEGISLATURE HAVE A BALANCED
APPROACH.
BUT WE DIDN'T DO GRANT THE
AUTHORITY THE AGE YOU JUST
CREATE THAT LAST UPDATED
PERIODICALLY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE'S CITIES.
THE FAIRNESS OF HOW THAT LIST
GETS CREATED MAINTAINED THAT IT
DOES REFLECT THIS LIFESAVING
TEND TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
URBAN SUBURBAN RURAL.
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MATTER
PUBLIC POLICY BEING ENTRUSTED TO
THEIR CARE.
AND WITH THAT I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE ADDITION OF
THIS NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SMALL
COUNTIES.
WHICH WILL COVER TWENTY NINE OF
THE STATE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
IS ITSELF A A GOOD COMPANION
PROVISION. TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE PROGRAMS THERE AND DOLLARS
HERE TO SUPPORT EVERY COUNTY TO
BECOME COMPLIANT TO GET ON THAT
PRO HOUSING LIST.
TRY I THINK THAT THERE IS GOOD
BALANCE WITHIN THIS LOOKING OUT
THROUGH THE LENS OF SMALL CITIES
AROUND CALIFORNIA.
BUT I DO SAY IS A LAWMAKER.
WE ARE MAKING A BROAD DELEGATION
OF AUTHORITY HERE AND I THINK
WE'LL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS APTLY EXERCISE GOING
FORWARD.
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COLLEY MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS I WANT TO JOIN IN THE
CHORUS OF SUPPORT FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR HOMELESS
SERVICES AROUND THE STATE AND
FOR HOUSING AROUND THE STATE.
I THINK IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT THIS IS ONE OF OUR A MOST
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH ONE OF
OUR MOST COMPLEX ISSUES AND AND
ONE OF THOSE THAT IS MOST.
DIFFICULT TO SOLVE AND YES THE
COST OF PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HAS RISEN IT'S A
CHALLENGE WE NEED TO FIND WAYS --
TO TRYIN LOWER THAT COST OF
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
FOLKS WHO WHO NEED IT.
BUT WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF THE
CURRENTCRISIS AND AS WE ASK.
UP FOLKS AROUND THE STATE WHO
ARE REPORTING THE RESULTS OF
HOMELESS COUNCIL WE KNOW THAT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS IS UP 12%.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THAT
NUMBER 16% -- THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD NOT ACCEPT BUT
THE NUMBER ONE DRIVER -- THAT
WAS SET ASCERTAIN THROUGH THE
HOMELESS COUNT IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOSING THEIR HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOUSING HAS BECOME TOO
EXPENSIVE FOR THEM SO THE THEIR
GOT THAT LAST RENT INCREASE.
THAT OF THAT YOU KNOW THEY JUST
COULDN'T MAKE AND THERE ON THE
STREET.
ARE THE COULD MAKE THE PAYMENT
ON OR PERHAPS THEY LOST A JOB
AND COULDN'T MAKE THEIR NEXT
RENT PAYMENT BUT THAT'S WHY SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE ON THE STREET.
IN LOS ANGELES WE HAVE HOUSE
MORE PEOPLE THAN EVER BEFORE BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH THE RISING TIDE OF
HOMELESSNESS.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
THIS FUNDING WILL BE HELPFUL I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER TING YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AGAIN
JUST TO SUMMARIZE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID WITH A THE LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS WELL AS
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS PEOPLE.
ON OUR STREETS AT ALL TIME HIGH
WE ARE ACTUALLY AT CRISIS LEVEL
THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR IN A ROW
THAT WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT --
FUNDING INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
AREAS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR
AB ONE A ONE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
SENATE MINUTES ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
AC ARE SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE OFFICER NATALIE CORONA
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR SIXTY
SIX FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS RESOLUTION NAMES AN
APPROXIMATE A FIVE MILE STRETCH
OF INTERSTATE FIVE IN OUR BUCKLE
AS THE OFFICER NATALIE CORONA
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
DAVIS ROOKIE POLICE OFFICER NOW
THE CORONA WAS JUST TWENTY TWO
YEARS OLD WHEN SHE WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY GUNMEN WELL A DUTY ON
THE EVENING OF JANUARY TENTH
THIS YEAR.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
MYSELF AND MEMBERS OF MY STAFF
ATTENDED HER MEMORIAL SERVICE
AND THE DAVIS AND COLUSA CAN'T
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO MOURN
HER TRAGIC DEATH.
EVERY PERSON I'VE SPOKEN TO
ABOUT NOW LEE SAYS THAT SHE WAS
DESTINED FOR GREAT THINGS.
SHE EXEMPLIFIED WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE COMMITTED TO OUR JOB IN
HELPING OTHERS.
ACR SIXTY SIX WOMAN MARK
MEMORIALIZED OFFICER NOW THE
CORONA.
AND FOREVER REMIND US OF ALL THE
HER BEAUTIFUL LIFE.
AND HER COMMITMENT TO SERVICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THREE GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
JUST WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION -- OFFICER
NARROWLY CORONAS WAS A BRIGHT
LIGHT IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN OUR
BUCKLE -- COLUSA COUNTY -- HER
FATHER WAS A LONGTIME DEPUTY
SHERIFF AND CURRENT COUNTY
SUPERVISOR IN COLUSA COUNTY --
AND THEY RAISED HER WELL.
AND SHE WENT INTO KNOWING ALL
THE THINGS THAT GO ALONG WITH
BEING A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
HAVING SEEN THAT FIRSTHAND --
BEING THE DAUGHTER.
OF A DEPUTY SHERIFF.
SHE WANTED TO IT WITH WIDE EYES
AND BEING AT THAT MEMORIAL IN
DAVIS WITH MY COLLEAGUE -- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME
[inaudible]
MOST WAS.
THAT HER FATHER SAID GOD INDEED
CALLED HER TO THIS. TO THIS
PROFESSION AND EVEN CALLED HER
TO THAT.
ACCIDENT SITE THAT NIGHT -- THAT
AMAZING FACE AND AND STRENGTH.
THERE WAS SHOWN IN THAT FAMILY.
OBVIOUSLY WAS EXEMPLIFIED IN
THEIR DAUGHTER -- AND SO IT.
WE HAVE REALLY HEAVY HEARTS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVING LOST HER --
BUT WE KNOW THAT SHE'S IN A MUCH
BETTER PLACE -- AND SHE IS LEFT
A LEGACY.
THAT WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND SO I ASKED THAT WE SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION.
TODAY MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
BOUGHT THIS THIS MORNING OR THIS
AFTERNOON. FOR ALL OF US HERE IN
THIS BUILDING AS WELL AS A
FAMILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BECAUSE THIS ACR IS
FISCAL REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS OF YOUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
MOVING.
TO FILE ITEM ONE SB TWO HUNDRED
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED BY
CINEMARK ANOTHER'S INOCULATED
DRINKING WATER MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO CLEAR
THE YEARS HERE OF SIGNIFICANT
MEDIALLY.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AFTER THREE YEARS OF RELENTLESS
ADVOCACY AND COUNTLESS.
COMMUNITY TOURS BUS TRIPS TO THE
CAPITAL VOICES OF FAMILIES HERE
VISITING EVERY SINGLE OFFICE
TELLING US HOW IMPORTANT CLEAN
WATER IS. FOR THE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT DON'T HAVE IT.
WE HAVE A BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
SENATE BILL.
TWO HUNDRED IT REPRESENTS A
COMPROMISE PLAN TO PROVIDE A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOLUTION. FOR
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
I WANT TO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
OUR LEADERSHIP HERE OF THE
ASSEMBLY AS WELL AS THE SENATE
FOR CRAFTING THIS SOLUTION AND
HAVING THE COURAGE. TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS IN AN IMMEDIATE AND
IMPACTFUL WAY.
SPECIFICALLY SB TWO HUNDRED WILL
ESTABLISH A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUN UNDER THE
DIRECTION THE STATE WATER BOARD.
I WILL TRANSFER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION A YEAR FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
UNTIL THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY TO
PAY FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER
SOLUTIONS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THE MEASURE REQUIRES A WATER
BOARD TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO DEVELOP
AN ANNUAL EXPENDITURE PLAN ON
HOW BEST TO ADMINISTER.
AND DISTRIBUTE FUNDING IN
RESPONSIBLE COST EFFECTIVE
MANNERS.
THAT PRIORITIZES SOLUTIONS FOR
THOSE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY UNSAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
IN DEVELOPING THE FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN THE WATER BOARD
MUST CONSULT WITH AN ADVISORY
GROUP MADE UP OF WATER SYSTEM
REPRESENTATIVES.
LOCAL AGENCIES AND RESIDENTS
SERVE BY WATER SYSTEMS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
ADDITIONALLY SB TWO HUNDRED
SPECIFIES A NARROW ALLOWABLE
USES OF THIS FUNDING TO ENSURE
FUNDS ARE SPENT IN A TRANSPARENT.
AND COST EFFECTIVE MANNER THAT
ADDRESSES THE ROOT BARRIERS TO
PROVIDING SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
MEMBERS THE FAMILIES -- THAT
HAVE VISITED OUR OFFICE OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS ABOUT THIS ISSUE
COME FROM ALL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE FINALLY HAVE A SOLUTION THAT
WILL MOVE FORWARD IN BEGINNING
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BUT THE
WORK WITH SB TWO HUNDRED ISN'T
DONE.
THE BE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT COMES AFTER SB TWO HUNDRED
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY -- I IN TERMS OF
WHERE THESE FUNDS ARE BEING USED
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
I WANT TO JUST AGAIN THE
KNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA FROM
PAY WORK AND OF COURSE THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR SPEAKER FOR
BRINGING THIS MAJOR FORWARD.
AND THANK EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SAM MISTER
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THE PURSUIT TO GET CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN OUR STATE HAS
BEEN A LONG.
ONE THIS IS BEEN SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN WORKING AT FOR AT LEAST THE
LAST FIVE YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN
ELECTED.
AND WE'VE GONE AROUND AND HAD
MANY MANY DIFFERENT AGREEMENTS
ON WHAT WE ALL THINK THE RIGHT
FUNDING FORMULA IS.
BUT SB TWO HUNDRED ISN'T ABOUT
THE FUNDING.
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED FROM CALIFORNIA'S
DROUGHTS.
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED FROM OUR AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING.
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS FAMILIES.
HAVE CLEAN POSSIBLE DRINKING
WATER.
IT'S INSURING THAT OUR STATE.
STICKS TO OUR WORD.
AS WE DID IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE MAKING CLEAN
DRINKING WATER A RIGHT.
IN THIS STATE.
MEMBERS I ENCOURAGE YOU. TO
SUPPORT SB.
TWO HUNDRED ENSURE THAT OUR
FAMILIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AT
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO HUNDRED IT'S SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE.
THAT DO NOT HAVE SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER -- IN IN FACT
MORE THAN A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TO RELY ON PURCHASING WATER
HAULING IT INTO THEIR HOMES
BECAUSE THE WATER COMING OUT OF
THEIR TAP IS ON SAFE.
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY GOING ON
FOR FAR TOO LONG.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES UGH MR GARCIA --
SENATOR MINING -- EXCUSE ME THE
THE MEMBER FROM THE FROM THE
DESERT -- BUT I THIS IS AN ISSUE
WHOSE TIME HAS FINALLY COME AND
I HAVE -- TRIED IN A MY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS FOR A CLEAN DRINKING
WATER WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO DO
IT ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
I AM IT'S TIME FOR THERE TO BE A
CONTINUOUS SOURCE OF FUNDING.
BECAUSE WITH ONE TIME MONEY WE
CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
WE DID HAVE MULTIPLE PLACES OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT
WE'VE LOOKED TO TO PROVIDE THIS
FUNDING EACH ONE HAD ITS
SUPPORTERS EACH ONE HAD ITS
DETRACTORS WERE LANDING TODAY ON
THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
FUND -- IT'S AN OPTION FRANKLY
NOT MY FIRST CHOICE.
BUT IN MY OPINION GOING FORWARD.
WE SHOULD BE USING THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FUND.
IN WAYS THAT MORE FULLY ALIGNED
WITH THE GOALS OF THAT FUND AND
I HOPE THAT EVENTUALLY WILL BE
ABLE TO OUGHT TO FIND AN
ALTERNATIVE SOURCE.
BUT FOR NOW THIS IS THE BEST
SOLUTION THAT WE HAVE AN SP TWO
HUNDRED OFFERS US A GREAT START
ON RESTORING SAFE DRINKING WATER
THE WANT TO THOSE.
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS IT LAYS THE
FOUNDATION FOR A LONG TERM
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
SB TWO HUNDRED CREATES.
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUNDED IT AUTHORIZES THE
PURPOSES FOR THE USE OF THE FUND
REQUIRES AN EXPENDITURE PLAN.
BUT IT'S JUST A START.
SB TWO HUNDRED PROVIDES THE
FOUNDATION BUT NOT THE STRUCTURE
AS THE FLOOR ANALYSIS NOTES IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE THE PROGRAM AND
PRIORITIES FOR HOW THE STATE
WATER BOARD WILL RESTORE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
AND IN THE YEAR AHEAD.
WE WILL STILL NEED TO SET THOSE
PRIORITIES GIVE THE BOARD
DIRECTION AND PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR HOW THE BOARD
MOVES FORWARD TO OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE.
IN RECENT YEARS THE BOARD IS
HIRED PRIVATE CONSULTANTS ARE
NON PROFITS TO HELP INDIVIDUAL
WATER SYSTEMS IN SOME RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WHILE IT IS HAD ACCESS TO
WATER BOND FUNDS FOR FUNDS FOR
CAPITAL PROJECTS LIKE TREATMENT
PLANTS IT IS HAD LIMITED FUNDING
FOR SOFT COSTS.
AND COULD ONLY DO SO MUCH SO NOW
SB TWO HUNDRED IN THE STATE
BUDGET.
INJECTS A SUBSTANTIAL INFUSION
OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
THIS BILL CHANGES THE EQUATION
AND WILL DEMAND THAT THE STATE
BOARD SUBSTANTIALLY RAMP UP ITS
EFFORTS TO GET SAFE DRINKING
WATER TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
HOW IS THE BOARD GOING TO SCALE
UP WELL THE BILL DOES NOT GIVE
THE BOARD NEW AUTHORITY OR
DIRECTION ON HOW TO SCALE UP?
AND I THINK ONE PART OF THE
ANSWER IS ENGAGING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS PARTICULARLY
SUCCESSFUL WATER AGENCIES THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE.
TO SET FAILING WATER SYSTEMS ON
A NEW SUSTAINABLE PATH WE NEED
ALL HANDS ON DECK APPROACH. TO
SAFE TO THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCY THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING SO NEXT YEAR AB ONE
THIRTY FOUR WILL DO EXACTLY THAT
AND ENGAGE ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
IN HOW THE BOARD CAN DO THAT
SCALING SETTING PRIORITIES AND
SETTING DIRECTION AND GIVING THE
BOARD AUTHORITY THE AUTHORITY
THAT IT NEEDS TO SUCCEED.
SO THE CALIFORNIA CAN OVERCOME
IT SAFE DRINKING WATER
CHALLENGES.
SB TO HUNDRED IS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO HUNDRED ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING WITHOUT
SAFE WATER THAT THEY CAN DEPEND
ON IN MANY CASES THIS IS BECAUSE
OF CONTAMINATION.
IT IS MY CONVICTION THAT
POLLUTERS MUST PAY.
I AM PROUD OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC SUCCESS BUT IT IS
MEANINGLESS IF IT IS ON THE
BACKS OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
LIVING IN RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES WITH CONTAMINATED
WATER.
THOSE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
ESPECIALLY LARGE AND IMPORTANT%
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS MUST
STEP UP.
AND ACCEPT THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
WE AS A STATE MUST ENSURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
EVEN AS WE PURSUE ACCOUNTABILITY
WE MUST ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
TURN ON THEIR TAPS.
AND NOT WORRY ABOUT THE GLASSES
OF WATER THEY GET FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING TODAY
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND.
IT IS A WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO BE A PIONEER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
IN SUCH A PROSPEROUS STATE IT IS
AN EMBARRASSMENT TO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO CANNOT GET CLEAN WATER.
BECAUSE IT COSTS TOO MUCH.
THIS IS HOW WE CAN PUT THAT
EMBARRASSMENT BEHIND US.
I ASKED FOR IT I VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER THIRD OF A ALL
MEMBERS.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE -- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS HERE ON THE URGENCY AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO ON THE BILL MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO THE THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FIVE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT
THESE AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MINING THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE IN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THAT
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL.
AND THEY MAKE THE OPPONENTS GO
NEUTRAL SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
YOU MISTER STAND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ACCEPTED OUT
TO PRINT AND BACK TO FILE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTY FIVE
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE WITH
A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS ADDERS TOO CLOSE TO
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE IN CONCURRENCE --
SKEWS ME -- ON THE MINUTES
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
AMENDMENTS ARE ACCEPTED OUT TO
BRING HIM BACK TO FILE.
WE WILL MOVE. TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS NINETY ONE
THROUGH ONE OH FOUR DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE FOURTH OF JULY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO AGAIN THANK COUNTERS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL EIGHTEEN I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SO THE BILL ONCE
EVERY THREE NINE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE BILL TWO FORTY TWO I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE BILL
SEVEN A ONE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
BILL'S OF FORTY EIGHT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO. ZERO SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH URGENCY I SIXTY
SEVEN NOTES HERE ON THE URGENCY
AYE SIXTY SEVEN IS YOUR ON THE
BILL.
SENATE BILL FIVE AWAIT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTY I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY NINE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
MONDAY JULY EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW.
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE IN MEMORY OF LOS
ANGELES ANGELS PITCHER TYLER
SKAGGS.
MISTER SKAGGS WAS BORN IN
WOODLAND HILLS CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE BUT FOR MOST
OF HIS LIFE AS A RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA.
SKAGGS ATTENDED SANTA MONICA
HIGH WHERE HIS MOTHER DEBBIE WAS
A LONG TERM LONG TIME SOFTBALL
COACH AT SANTA MONICA HIGH.
SHE FAMOUSLY PROVIDED POSTGAME
TIPS ON HIS PITCHING MECHANICS
AND THIS HAPPENED DEEP INTO HIS
BIG LEAGUE CAREER.
AT SANTA MONICA HIGH HIS
VELOCITY KEPT RISING SO MUCH SO
THAT PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL
RATHER THAN COLLEGE BASEBALL
BECAME IS NUMBER ONE OPTION AND
IN FACT HE WAS TAKEN BY THE
ANGELS OF THE FORTIETH PICK.
AS A SUPPLEMENTAL SELECTION IN
THE FIRST ROUND OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE DRAFT.
HE WAS THEN TRADED TO THE
ARIZONA DIAMONDBACKS IN TWENTY
TEN AND TRADED BACK TO THE
ANGELS.
IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN SKAGGS WAS ONE
OF THE MOST POPULAR PLAYERS IN
THE CLUBHOUSE A PLAYER WHO LOVE
TALKING ABOUT HIS TWO FAVORITE
TEAMS.
THE LAKERS AND THE MINNESOTA
VIKINGS.
AND HE WAS A PLAYER WHO REVELLED
IN TEAM ACTIVITIES LIKE DRESS UP
DAY WHEN THE ANGELS.
HAD FOR THEIR SUNDAY NIGHT PLATE
TO TEXAS AND ALL DONNED WESTERN
THEME TO TIRE.
ENTER HANEY A STARTER ALONGSIDE
SKAGGS.
SAID THAT THE FELLOW LEFT HANDER
WAS HIS BEST FRIEND AND STATED.
THERE'S PROBABLY ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT WOULD SAY HE WAS OUR BEST
FRIEND.
TO BECAUSE HE TREATED EVERYBODY
LIKE THAT HE JUST HAD AN
INFECTIOUS PERSONALITY.
THE ENERGY THAT TYLER WAS SAID
TO BRING TO THE CLUBHOUSE.
PICKED ME UP EVERY TIME I SAW
HIM SAID MIKE TROUT.
HE WAS MAGNETIC SAID GENERAL
MANAGER BILLY OPPLER.
HE WAS GENEROUS AND KIND AND OUR
TEAM WILL NEVER BE THE SAME
WITHOUT HIM.
BUT FOREVER WE'VE BEEN MADE
BETTER BY HIM.
SKAGGS TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY
SUDDENLY LAST WEEK ON THIS WEEK
ON JULY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN HE WAS ONLY
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CARLY
AND HIS MOTHER DEBBIE AND I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO A GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF KENNETH EUGENE BEARING.
WHO PASSED AWAY JUNE TWENTY
FIFTH AT THE AGE OF?
NINETY ONE CAN WAS A NOTED EAST
BAY PHILANTHROPIST AND GIVE AWAY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DONATIONS.
TO MUSEUMS UNIVERSITIES AND MANY
CHARITIES.
INCLUDING THE LARGEST SINGLE
CONTRIBUTION OF EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE HISTORY. TO THE
SMITH SMITHSONIAN INSTITUTE.
IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND CAN FOUNDED
THE WHEELCHAIR FOUNDATION WITH A
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR IN DOWN.
THE FOUNDATION SOON BECAME A
DIVISION OF BERING'S GLOBAL
HEALTH AND EDUCATION FOUNDATION.
BY TWO THOUSAND SIX THE
WHEELCHAIR WHEELCHAIR FOUNDATION
DELIVER MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHEELCHAIRS. TWO PEOPLE
IN ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
COUNTRIES.
AND IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE FOUNDATION
HAD SURPASSED THAT MARK.
WITH ONE MILLION TOTAL
WHEELCHAIRS.
MR BEARING IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE PAT OF MORE THAN SIXTY NINE
YEARS. FOUR CHILDREN TEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GREAT.
GRANDCHILDREN.
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER BEARING.
REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESTINY PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUEST RETURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASSED ENTERTAINED ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES IN MISTER FRAZIER
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY JULY
EIGHTH AT ONE PM